[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: David
Bayles, American writer,
is the author of
Art and Fear book
says, "creativity
opens access to worlds
that can be dangerous,
unapproachable, forbidden,
attractive, or all at once."
We live in an amazing time full
of unlimited possibilities.
The time for freedom
of self-expression.
That time when
experiments are conducted
not only on content, but also
on the form of submitting
this content.
Creativity has become
inaccessible for many of us,
not just for the
limited groups of people
who give this
process a lifetime.
Now it's the best
time to create,
because technologies
have become affordable.
Almost every person now
has a smartphone equipped
with a high quality camera.
With the usual gadget, you
can create amazing images
and video material.
Every day I see a huge number
of very artistic pictures
that people upload to Instagram.
And I shoot it too.
The photos they create are
a reflection of their life.
For example, a
sailor is sketching
an ocean, and life on his ship.
The astronaut from ISS shooting
the earth through the porthole.
A young mother taking a
photo of her sleeping child,
or beautiful macro photograph
filmed through the [INAUDIBLE]..
Spending 10 or 20
minutes per day,
you can create beautiful images.
And you don't need a
professional studio,
because all the world around
you is enough for shooting.
And you don't need a
special light equipment,
because ordinary window--
it's quite enough, too.
This is the creativity which was
always with us, in our pockets.
Talking about most serious
photographic equipment
and professional image
quality, these things
also became more
affordable for us,
with mirrorless
cameras and advances
in compacts in the form
of point and shoot.
Talking about the
analog photography,
it's now experiencing
another heyday.
Great photo laboratories
with the possibility
of digitizing the film.
The process has [INAUDIBLE]
to be inaccessible.
In the world, if we want
to shoot on a camera,
now it's much more
easier than 10 years ago.
Digital technology
develops every day.
More and more people
learn and invent
a wide range of different
professional techniques.
Knowledge has also
become more affordable.
Thanks to content
platforms such as YouTube,
you can get an answer
to almost any question.
My 75-year-old
father also uses it
when he needs to fix
something in the house.
Probably you already
know, YouTube now
is the second largest
search engine in the world.
You can find the visual manual
for any technique or visual
practice you use, and
those how-to videos are
in your pockets today,
and in mine, too--
24 hours, seven days per
week, just all the time,
inside our smartphones.
There is a huge
amount of resources
with useful articles about
photography, community sites,
blogs, where people can share
their accumulated experience,
and it's cool.
Unlimited communication spreads
information with great speed.
There are a lot of different
specialized training platforms,
websites, where you can catch
and watch interesting video
courses created in a very
usable format for a low price,
sometimes in format of monthly
or annual subscription.
I hope you use it.
We can watch interviews of
our favorite photographers,
and backstage of their
shootings in a nonstop mode.
Such communication is led by
creative individuals, as well
as monsters like a Vogue
magazine, for example.
On their official
YouTube channel,
you can watch the back
stage for shootings,
then you can go directly
to the digital version
of the shooting asset, and
clearly track the whole flow,
starting from the
preparation, choosing
the most relevant
technique, and then checking
out the final edit.
As this still doesn't
engage the engagement
in higher education, of course,
if you have such motivation.
But it certainly helps to
begin to engage in creativity
and gain answers to
many questions that
arise inside your head.
Borders matter less and less.
Modern technology's evolution
gives us the opportunity
to be invisibly
present even in those
places where we don't exist yet,
or in places we need to visit.
With the sun-tracking
mobile apps,
such as Sun Follower
or Sun Position,
you can easily examine and
predict the position of sun
at anytime, on any day,
in any shooting locations.
You can monitor the weather,
predicting the rain or fog.
In a blink of an eye, we can
get any information we need--
and this doesn't require
physical presence
at the time and the place.
We can always turn to the joint
experience of other people
who have already visited this
area and shared their advice.
Thanks to lovely Google
View, we can spend hours
exploring different
areas of the cities,
marking the interesting houses
and making up a filming route
for the future projects.
I surely feel this--
a freedom of movement.
Traveling has been never
so reasonable and easy.
With low cost airlines,
you can find yourself
in few hours in any
geographical areas
and new visual conditions.
Unlimited audience.
For a long time, people
who create images
could reach their audience
only through magazines
and newspapers, or through
galleries and museums.
We know many cases when a
creative person became known
only after his or her death.
For example, legendary
Vivian Mayer.
An American street
photographer, this woman
took genius pictures--
more than 150,000 photographs.
But they were discovered
and appreciated only
after her death.
I am sure that nowadays, with
all of these online platforms
and social networks,
Vivian Mayer
would have been recognized
in her lifetime.
She'd be seen, shared, and
exhibited around the world.
Now everything we
do can be viral--
and saying "viral," I
say it in a good way.
Here is a story about
one of my works--
probably about the
most famous one.
[INAUDIBLE] it's called,
[INAUDIBLE] and Pandora--
her dog adopted from the street.
I have no idea how many times
it was transferred as a tattoo
to somebody's skin.
But I know for sure that
this work is replicated
by different street
artists from Europe,
and they depict it on streets
and houses again and again.
It happened during an
absolutely ordinary shooting.
After the shooting,
[INAUDIBLE] the model,
edited the photo with
color, and changed the color
of the artist's
[INAUDIBLE] in that eye,
and uploaded it to
her Tumblr for a joke.
The next day brought
hundreds of posts.
Since this image is experiencing
a snowball effect, still now.
It was posted by [INAUDIBLE].
It was published
hundreds of times
in different
communities and blogs.
It also was published as the
cover of German newspaper Die
Zeit.
And I super happy, and grateful.
You know, guys, during the
preparation for this talk,
I was planning to show this
picture in a very nice way.
But then I decided to show
it as we see it often--
on the screens of
our gadget, framed
with our social profiles.
It is the way how we now
look at the picture, mostly.
So back into the photo with
Pandora and [INAUDIBLE]..
This image begins to
live its own life,
and its very similar how
its my child, my son David,
making his own
steps in this world,
and I'm just watching him.
I'm absolutely sure
that such a story would
be impossible without the
internet, and the opportunities
that it gives to us.
Collaborative creativity.
There is one excellent
documentary I have seen.
It's called "PressPausePlay."
It explores the unlimited
opportunities and challenges
behind the technology of
collaborative creativity.
The collaborative creativity
can be very different.
For example, I can
shoot video footage
and transfer it through
Google Disk or through Proxy
to my video edit room,
living in another city
or in another country.
We can meet online, and discuss
our tasks without meeting off
line, of course.
And then I'm just
going to shoot again,
and he is starting to
work on his material.
In such a way, I working
also with retired artists.
It's absolutely easy
to communicate also
with the curator of
your gallery, now,
and together, in a visual
format, using a shared desktop,
try to shuffle and move
the places for photos
to find the optimal arrangement
for your future exhibition.
Our times allows us to engage
in very interesting forms
of visual creativity, which
I would call a collage.
Here you can see a few
of my favorite authors.
And the ways they reinterpret
the classical painter art
works, integrating them
into modern format,
and help us to look at
them in a totally new way.
It's [INAUDIBLE],,
it's [INAUDIBLE],,
and also, it's Fat Cat Art.
A nice profile.
Maybe you know this.
Someone will say
that it's sacrilege.
But I think that
it's a second life,
and a new win for the classics.
David Bayles' quote--
"with your creativity
you show what is important
to you as a person."
It's quite important
to brand yourself
as an artist and creator.
There are many options for this,
but too often, creative people
have a fear inside themselves.
Fear of telling who we are.
Fear of telling what we do.
Many others continue working,
but never showing their art
for years, creating
amazing things
but still waiting for some
special moment to show.
The moment that
you are waiting for
is actually happening right now.
It's important to
understand someone, maybe
on the other part
of Earth, maybe
in the next house in Dublin,
is waiting on your creations--
waiting.
He wants to see it.
He wants to interact emotionally
with your creativity.
I think it's crucial to show
your work and get feedback.
Of course, the core
audience wouldn't
be created immediately.
Sometimes, you need months or
years to grow it from scratch.
That's OK.
But here's the main thing--
your potential viewers,
fans, followers,
are always here, near us--
here.
You just need to define
who are these people, which
social networks they use,
which platforms they visit,
and how to start communication
with them and your art.
Let's look at another
story about me.
For a long time,
I tried to combine
photography, video directing
and shooting, and teaching
photography.
And on this question,
"what are you doing, man?"
My answer was very long.
This gave a rather scattered
perception of me as the author,
because each listener understood
it somehow in his way.
My team and I created
a clear statement
to put everything on its place.
I create human visuals.
In this situation,
I act as an artist,
as a visual storyteller, using
various visual practice to tell
the stories about the people.
Sometimes, it's not so important
to have special skills,
because you can work
on it, develop it--
it will certainly grow.
But it's important to
understand something else.
What is really important
and interesting
for you, as a person?
The stories about other people
are important and interesting
for me.
My focus area is the creative
person, the creative process--
ability of people to create.
The heroes of my
projects are important.
They are artists, directors,
actors, and musicians--
but also representatives of
completely different cultures.
Shifts, bartenders, craftsmen,
fisherman, farmers, and so on.
At the same time, families
and human relations as topics
are also very important for me.
Because I know that
it's also a great work,
and a great creativity.
By defining the most
important area for me,
I can work and create, then,
more narrowly serious--
serious projects in this area.
This is what I'm always telling
my students-- ask yourself
the right questions, and
adjust your activities
to the area of your interests.
Tools I use to tell
about my works.
First, my personal website.
There is my portfolio,
so people can quickly
understand who am
I, what I am doing,
and what type of projects
I want to do in the future.
A visual blog-- to
save and post images.
It's on Instagram.
It enables people to
follow my activity,
to see different content,
access streams, and stories too.
Sure, I'm using a profile
resource for creative people,
such as Behance.
Their open access to
the creative community
allows me to interact
with other artists
and follow their
working projects too.
And of course, I use Facebook
as a means of communication
with my potential students,
customers, and viewers.
There is a wonderful book.
It's called "Art and
Fear," by David Bayles.
And I highly recommend
it to everyone
who still believes that
the moment for publishing
their work has not yet come.
Do not be afraid of criticism.
Really.
It's capable of injury, but
it's not capable of killing us.
The most important
thing is the movement
and constant reflection of
the experience that we get.
We have to get more experience--
more and more experience.
It's moving us.
Any failure gives us
much more information
for further progress
than success.
The main thing is
just to comprehend it.
Umberto Eco, the famous
writer, says, "postmodernism
is the answer to modernism--
since the past
can't be destroyed,
for its destruction
leads to dumbness,
its need to be rethought,
ironically, without naivety."
Now, the classic,
in its pure form,
no longer causes such
emotions as before.
Many photographers
are completely
immersed in experiments
with the form,
and trying to find
something different.
Frankly, not all of
these experiments
are completely
understandable to me,
and I don't like them, at all.
New time we're living--
asking for us the new questions.
How?
What for?
And who are you?
Who's shooting?
Answering the question, "how?"
I decided myself was the best
way, for me, is neoclassicism--
as in music.
I will now not relate most
of the classical settings,
in the terms of visual
language of photography,
but I will mix them.
For example, using
some modern shooting
techniques as a
Fuji or Polaroid.
More modern lighting--
[INAUDIBLE],, not classic.
And the heroes of
my work, I will
choose as iconic
characters of our era.
With all of this, I will
make my visual language
accessible to the widest
possible audience.
So it creates
something like Ikea--
something like Ikea in the
field of photographic language.
Something simple,
understandable, in terms
of form and accessible
for perception.
Perhaps it will be
incomprehensible
to some critics and viewers who
want to see a complex image.
But as I said earlier, my task
is to tell the whole stories.
Its my main task.
So I don't need to surprise
somebody with the form
every time.
If you try to think about
the question "what for?"
I believe that art can
ask certain questions
to the viewer, giving him the
opportunity to think about it.
And also, I believe
that problems
can be told not only
from the site of problem.
I believe that the
declaration of values
is an alternative way of
visualizing the problems.
I believe that photography--
and art, in general--
are able to influence
the minds of people.
And when you impress them
with your creativity,
you slowly change their
attitude to those topics
that you have raised.
These two topics, I
will talk about two
of my personal projects.
One of them is devoted to the
topic of family and couples
who have lived together
more than 30 years.
The other is devoted to
the topic of fatherhood.
We will see it later.
These two topics are now
extremely important to me
as a man.
These pictures have a
certain social connotation.
These are stories where
everyone can read what
he is ready for, for this time.
And the second answer to
the question, "what for?"
is a study, also.
I love to learn.
By doing a project on a
theme, you automatically
immerse yourself
and study the theme.
Photography, in this
case, can be in our method
of cognition [INAUDIBLE].
The third, and the last answer
of the question of "what for?"
is a declaration of
a value of a person.
Portrait photography always
expresses the author's attitude
to people, you know?
And just in this case,
with the help of portrait,
you can tell that a
person in this world
takes very little
space, but means a lot.
You can tell that
there is nothing
more attractive, complex,
and contradictory
in this world than a human.
The answer to the question,
"who are you?" is simple enough.
I understand that
I am an artist.
But I like when my works
speaks about me more than me.
So I teach only because the
intensive practice and a lot
of experience is
accumulated, and I
want to share it with others.
I teach because the ability of
people to share experience--
I think it's the
most and main driving
force of our civilization.
You are now what you have
absorbed and learned.
And therefore, the author living
in post-modern era is equally
influenced by classics
of world culture,
and unknown or known
contemporary authors--
whom we can meet
in the internet.
At some point, the author
with 3K subscribers
living in Bangladesh can
mean exactly the same to you
as Sir [INAUDIBLE],, Lindbergh,
[INAUDIBLE],, Newton, Ansel
Adams, and other classics.
And it's normal.
The main task as
the author living
in this time it's to be
choosy, but at the same time,
to be opened to different
kinds of experience--
not to close yourself.
Our study of other people's
experience, and interaction
with someone's art, gives
us birth to inspiration
and fullness that we
need to create something.
Inspiration is an oxygen
for creative people, as us.
It's almost impossible to
create anything without it.
I have been teaching
for nine years.
I have met several
global misconceptions
that photographers have.
Now, we will shortly
go through the list,
and perhaps someone will
find out himself there.
First misconception.
It seems to me that many of us
are waiting for inspiration,
like rain or sun.
Mostly rain-- I don't know.
[LAUGHS] Relying on some
internal weather forecast.
But I believe that the
ability to be inspired
is like muscles--
it needs to be rocked.
That is, if you want
to be productive,
creative unit, then you
must take certain efforts
to ensure that inspiration
doesn't leave you in any time.
A creative person should strive
to be constantly charged.
If you do not
consume what others
have created then
create, then there
will be no inspiration
from nowhere.
That second misconception
is "the more
I look at the works
of others, the more I
lose my individuality."
In my experience,
individuality and style
begins to form after
first two or three
years of intensive study in
one or another visual practice.
In all other cases,
in my opinion,
the outlook and
erudition comes out.
And the more a person studies
classics of his contemporaries,
the more he will learn
anew about the methods
that he can use-- or
he or she can use.
I believe that
erudition and knowledge
are the keys to everything.
They are analogs for
fundamental creative education,
which is not received by
every photographer, now.
The more saturated
your cultural layer
is, the most unusual product
as a result, you can create.
The third misconception--
and most importantly--
is a fallacy of
many photographers.
To grow yourself
as a photographer,
it's necessary to
look at the photos,
and think about photos only.
So here, we will talk about
some kind of deviation
from that tunnel vision--
from the focus of attention
precisely only on photo image.
Photography, for me, lies
between painting and cinema.
And sources of inspiration, in
fact, can be very different.
In my opinion, we can learn a
lot from classical paintings.
I have a strong belief that each
photographer must have at least
five favorite artists, at least
five favorite cinema directors,
and at least a five
favorite cameraman.
Many good ideas are born when
looking and famous paintings.
Any picture can become a
reference for a fashion
editorial for magazines, or
a separate project you do.
The same with the movies--
I think that movie
and TV series is worth
watching, carefully studying,
not only as a storyline,
but the visual component.
It's very important to
train yourself to take still
pictures from the movies.
And after all, every screenshot
you've taken is a photo.
So the paintings can teach us
a lot about the composition
and color, and then the
cinema can teach us the color
and light arrangement, as well.
But we do not dwell on these.
I want to develop
my idea further.
It seems for me that we can
learn photography not only
through painting and cinema.
Let's go.
I can mention the theater
as a very powerful source
of inspiration, because there
is also an acting world,
and the emotions.
And very serious work
with mise en scene,
like composition, was very often
found in photography, you know.
I can also mention the ballet,
and contemporary choreography,
because there we can understand
how the human body is arranged,
and also how it
moves, and how to work
with it in terms of plasticity
when shooting a portrait.
The artist has very,
very important tasks--
to be in constant resonance
with the world around him.
To feel it.
We now have two worlds
interpenetrating each other--
the online world, and
the offline world.
The artist stays somewhere in
the middle, looking in and out.
And there it seems
to me very important
to study any derivatives
of these two worlds
to analyze them, to try to
understand by all means.
I hear the thought that creative
people are often infantile.
Have you heard that?
But what we put in the
concept of infantilism?
It seems to me that we are
talking about freshness
of sensation, comparable to what
the children are experiencing
in their life.
Many people tend to
limit their world
to comfortable and
understandable forms,
almost canceling their ability
to be surprised by something
new, and lowering the details
of everything else that
surrounds them.
In opposite, the child
absorbs the world as a sponge,
paying attention to those
details that seem to us
insignificant and unimportant.
If we consider
infantilism in this way,
then I think that artists should
be infantile to some extent,
really.
I admit my own
infantilism, because I'm
trying to learn everything
new that appears
in offline and online worlds.
Only studying all
this, I can hope
that I will have not lost
the sense of context,
and I maintain a dialogue
with different social types
of characters I shoot,
with different age groups,
and differing backgrounds
of my heroes--
from the scientists to rappers.
Therefore, no matter how
strange it may sound--
sorry-- but Leonardo da Vinci
and the battle rap culture
is equally important for the
modern photographer working
with people.
The modern world
changed the attitude
to the exhibition place, too.
Now in addition to traditional
galleries and good museums,
in fact, we can enter an
exhibition space every time
we park pick up our phone.
I'm talking about three main
sources of visual inspiration.
Let's talk.
The first is the Google
Arts and Culture Service,
which allows us to visit
a large number of museums
in a visual format
without leaving our homes.
The second is Pinterest.
It's a social network of
sharing your good taste.
For artists, this
is a powerful tool.
So if you're engaged in some
kind of visual practice,
it's active introduction
of Pinterest--
it's simple necessary to you.
The third is Instagram.
Instagram is considered to
be a great evil, you know--
and a great good,
at the same time.
I can say that, over
the past two years,
the Instagram community has
evolved very much, as I see it.
People are no longer interested
in watching endless travel
photos with views of
Iceland, Kamchatka,
Yosemite Park, or Antarctica.
But it's still interesting
to watch some travelers.
In the end, in Q&A,
I can say about some
of my buddies who are
still traveling and doing
great pictures.
And in special format.
I can say with confidence
that Instagram now
has a lot of accounts
devoted to art.
This is a format of small
online galleries with curators,
and good taste is present.
Therefore, from time to
time, do a rebuilding
of your friend's feed.
It's a cruel thing,
but we have to do it.
And scrap out all irrelevant
content, leaving only
what really inspires you.
A few Instagram profiles which
I constantly look through--
it's a summer magazine.
It's a nowness.
It's a [INAUDIBLE].
And ignorant.
But there are many
related profiles,
so you can just press
a button-- related--
and found something
else, like that.
Another very important
thing for any artist
is constant self-actualisation.
It's important,
not only legibility
in terms of what we
consume, but also constant
reflection and awareness on
your own visual priorities.
In other words, if
you are photographing,
you should strive to understand
exactly how the picture you
want to make is to look like.
What does the photo of
your dream look like?
Pinterest seems to me a
very convenient platform
for self-actualisation,
because there, you
can select references
to absolutely any topics
and projects, and
easily share them
with the members of your
crew, to get into work.
In addition, I want to say,
again, about online education.
There are some
educational portals,
which are very nice, high
quality video courses.
I talk now about
Masterclass.com, Linda.com,
Skillshare, or
Russian [INAUDIBLE]..
It happens in such
convenient format,
that you can learn
with your gadget.
In a moment, you're going
to the urban transport
to work, or retire with
an interesting lesson
during a lunch break.
On Masterclass.com,
for example, you
can find a course
from Annie Leibovitz.
I hope you know her.
I consider Annie to
be the embodiment
of colossal efficiency,
and was super
happy to have the opportunity
to observe her works,
and not only her output,
but all the process.
And she going through-- she
is a life classic, you know.
If earlier, you needed
to go somewhere,
and to stay physically
for a while,
for education, now
all education content
is just backed up to the
size of tablet or phone.
It's very easy.
You know, when I started
photography 14 years ago,
I dealt with dial-up
squeaking modem.
I hope you remember this.
And three-in-five
format floppy disks.
We were bringing the
photos on the floppy disks
from internet cafes to house,
to watch it, to examine it,
to try to understand
how it's done.
Now, we are getting
all for a moment.
We were choking on the
lack of information.
But now, we are choking
on it's overflow.
Therefore, it is so important
to clearly understand
the real possibilities that
our time gives us, and isolate
the useful data sets
from the white noise.
Finally, I want to
say one more thing.
It's not necessary to surprise
the viewer with the form
every time.
We don't need it.
Very often, in the desire
to surprise everyone,
we depart from the essence--
and from the main task
that every photographer
has decided to himself.
In my case, it's a story I told.
A testimony about
somebody's life.
Sometimes we go into false art.
We want to be
unlike anybody else.
We want to get respect
from the community.
But in my opinion, this
is a slippery path.
This is how exactly the
moment when "who" begins
to dominate over the "what for."
The photo is taken in
order to transmit something
to the people.
And please, don't try to
complicate it too much.
First of all,
proceed from the fact
that we need to
send some message.
It should be understood,
also, that art as a form
is necessary for
the viewer, too.
With the help of
art photography,
we give people the opportunity
to travel, here and now,
within their own imagination.
Therefore, if you
have some tools
that you can use to make
a less ordinary photo,
in order to rethink
the reality, in order
to build new certain
reality, it must be done.
But don't forget that
it's only a form--
there is also the
content, somewhere.
Photography can fix something
ordinary and everyday,
or it can become something
sublime, something special.
It's all about our
interest as a person.
In conclusion, I can say
that many artists seek
to disassociate themselves
from the mainstream and mass
culture.
They are looking for
solitude, for galleries,
for dark, dark,
dark underground.
I do not understand that,
because they automatically
refuse a large audience.
For me, photography is
an opportunity to speak.
It's a language.
And I believe that,
to be in mainstream,
to be a part of mass
culture, does not
mean for me that I'm making
a deal with my conscience.
What is good about
the mainstream?
First of all, it's
very flexible.
You can create anything.
Second, it likes
hard working authors.
You can easily create
your own style,
and fill your works with themes
that seem important to you.
Now it's five exercises to
develop your creativity.
First, make notes of
your own thoughts.
Second, give yourself 15
minutes of visual inspiration,
and do it every day.
Third, develop a creative plan
to have one shooting per week,
to realize some
process of creation,
to learn something new.
Number four, create
a group or chat
for those who will
criticize your work.
Five, six people is
quite enough, this.
It can be a part
of your community.
It's very useful.
And number five, try to
write a short mini-script
about what you see every
day, feel every day,
recognize every day.
It will help to develop
your storytelling skill,
and focus more on the
characters of your photos,
or your videos, or your stories.
Doesn't matter.
OK.
Let's each of us have the
courage and inner strength
to choose their own
theme, and to work hard
on it until the surrounding
space begins to sag under us
and reflect our creativity.
That's all from me, for today.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: I wanted to
ask you as a fan--
so what did you tell to David--
there was a picture when he was
smoking a cigarette-- fantastic
picture.
What exactly were
your words, you know,
right before this moment when
he was having the cigarette?
What-- how do you work
with these celebrities?
Because you're a fan,
as well, I assume?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV:
I was shooting
David Lynch in Kiev, when he
came with this foundation,
the David Lynch Foundation.
You know, this
foundation is working
on transcendental meditation.
Last 20 years, David Lynch
working on not only cinema,
on meditation--
and writing the books.
Maybe somebody has read it.
So David came with a visit
of his foundation openings--
opening the part
of it in Ukraine.
And I got a booking for me to
make some portraits of him.
For first time, it
sounds very good.
I must have one
shooting for 15 minutes,
and the second shooting
for half an hour.
And that just became
a little bit crazy,
because such a
legend, for me, is--
for such time.
But as a result, I had two
shootings for four minutes,
every [INAUDIBLE].
It was a little bit crazy.
For the first day, I
became really crazy.
And after the shooting,
I just laid to the floor
and tried to breathe, because
I just became very nervous.
But I get ready
for the shooting.
It was in this cinema theater.
I brought there,
with my assistants,
a small studio with a blue
background, and lighting,
and so on.
And when I see him, I understood
that he's very tired, now.
Because many people--
around 25 or 30 people
were running around him.
The agents, the PR
directors, there
are some guys from
the foundation.
And he had elections,
he had many meetings.
So I just looked at him,
and he looked at me,
and I understood that this is
a legend, but for this moment,
it's a very tired legend.
And I don't want to make
some violate shooting on him.
So I know that he
loves to smoke.
And I said, David, just
sit and smoke for a bit.
Don't think about me, now.
I will just shoot
you from the side.
So I put the lighting.
And I gave two minutes,
maybe, of my four minutes.
You see?
Half.
I just gave it for this moment.
Because I wanted him
to be more comfortable.
And then I asked him to
come to the blue background.
And he said, OK,
only for two shots.
And I said, David, it
will be not for two--
it will be maybe 15
or 20 shots, but I
swear it will be
very quick, and I
won't be saying to do anything.
You just can stay
and stare at me,
and also, you can
continue smoking.
And this way, I feel some
sympathy going from him.
Because he understood that I
rely on him, and I see a man.
A man-- a human.
Not the functional man from
cinema, not the celebrity--
just a human.
And it was kind of humanity.
So the second shooting
was quite [INAUDIBLE],,
because I had to do many shots.
As in the first day,
his PR guys just
cropped all of my shooting
for several minutes.
So I get a big set-up
from several points,
shooting and testing my
light on their systems.
So I build some
kind of corridor.
And when David came, I
told him about my idea
about shooting a poster
for the documentary
about him coming to Ukraine.
And I showed him
the locations, and I
told him something
about ideas, because I
know that he is a
director, and he
likes when people
understand what I do now.
And also, he knew me.
He remembered me from
yesterday's shooting.
So it was quite comfortable.
And in the end, I
asked him to sit here--
it's too contrast,
here, on this screen.
But you can find this image on
Instagram and on the internet.
So for the last moment, I asked
him to think about something.
He's thinking now to
look in the window.
And then, in the
last shot, I asked
him to look in the camera.
And here is, now,
not a tired old man--
now, I think, that in this
photo, he's just quite legend.
As he is.
Because for me--
I told you about interest,
about your thinking
about the people who
you're shooting-- for me,
it's a legend.
For me, it's a giant part
of world cinema culture,
Twin Peaks.
For me, this person--
he was a friend
of Andy Warhol, and many
other legendary people.
So I feel this
person is legendary.
And I wanted, also,
to make this portrait
legendary-- with legendary, a
deep lighting, with big volume.
SPEAKER: It's fantastic.
Fantastic.
SERGEI SARAKHANOV:
So, It's true story.
SPEAKER: So you were doing a
workshop, if I'm not mistaken,
yesterday, here in Ireland.
Right?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: Yeah.
Yeah.
Here in Dublin.
SPEAKER: How do you like it,
working with Irish people?
How do you feel,
yourself, here, in Dublin?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: Oh--
it's quite a good question.
I'm a big fan of Irish culture,
because I have listened
to Irish music for many years.
I love Damien Rice.
I love Glen Hansard.
I like U2.
I have shot [INAUDIBLE],, as
a great musician, Irish born.
So-- and I watched
Dublin in movies, also.
I have seen several movies--
maybe somebody has seen it--
"Greenwhich Mean Time."
It's a great movie about
Belfast, about Great Britain.
And also some movies
about Dublin, too.
So it was nice meeting,
like with some old friend,
when I came here.
And also, I'm a
Norse-born person,
so for me, it's also kind
of a Northern country
with strong people.
A little bit, maybe, sometimes
bully, and something like that,
but with very kind hearts.
That's me, too.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER: And now, we will take
questions from the audience.
Do you guys have any questions?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: Guys,
let's speak, if you want.
I will be glad to
answer the questions.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
So, with David Lynch,
you directed him.
But I guess he's kind of used to
having the camera faced at him.
How do you do with,
like, regular people
that you have on your projects.
Where is the limit?
So how do you direct them,
and where do you stop?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: I'm
working with people
from creative sphere.
And when I see a strong author,
or person with some kind--
you know-- some
tyrannic character,
which some of famous
people are in such way.
First of all, I'm
doing with respect.
With great respect.
But I'm standing myself equal.
I don't go down.
I don't try to dominate.
I am doing with respect,
because I think that respect is
a base of good relationships.
And then, I'm also doing with
respect, if a person says,
"sorry, but I don't want you
shoot me from the right side.
My left side is better."
I'm trusting people.
Sometimes, I can do experiment,
and shoot from another side,
too.
But I want person who
I'm shooting to see
and understands that I am
doing it with patience,
and I am listening
to him or her.
I am watching him or her.
Because it's human photography,
and the main value, for me,
is the comfort of the
person, and feeling good
on the shooting.
AUDIENCE: My
question is, can you
talk a bit about your process?
Not maybe when you
worked for a commercial--
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: That's
also a creative process.
Yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: --because from, like,
dealing with different artists
[INAUDIBLE] and creative people,
I've found that people tend
to have--
maybe there's more.
But I meant two-- one,
is very structured.
You have a beginning,
and you have a plan,
and [INAUDIBLE]
project management.
And the other one is
very, like, flow-y,
where you're guided by your
intuition, and you begin,
but you don't know
where it's going to end.
[INAUDIBLE] know
what's going to happen.
Which one is this?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: It's
a very good question.
Thank you.
First of all, I'm trying to find
the balance between these two
polar meanings.
And on the first
shooting, because I
love to work with people
constantly, for years--
we're building
friends, relationships.
And sometimes we can--
don't make some
big shooting, just
make as a friendly
shooting, in [INAUDIBLE]..
But the first shooting is also--
it's always planned
good, with references,
with great location scouting.
With examining the
lighting conditions,
with the app I show--
it's really very nice app you
should try, if you're shooting.
It's good for landscape
photographers, portrait
photographers, and also
street photographers, too.
So first of all,
we are planning.
I am doing big research, and
a big pre-production process.
Because on the shooting, I
want only to shoot and speak.
We speaking many, many
times-- more than shooting.
The shooting coming for
two, three, or four hours.
But seriously, we shoot,
I think, 20 or 25 minutes
from this time.
All of this time
left, we are speaking.
And I speaking a lot of--
I'm trying to
examine the person,
and trying to
interview the person.
And also, the main task for me--
not only to know the person,
but to let the person know me.
Because it's also
very important.
And on the next
shootings, we can do it
as you tell-- going with flow,
going with creative process.
Many of my friends are
choreographers, dancers,
painters, and such
other guys from art.
So sometimes, we're doing just--
we don't know what we're doing.
But we-- in this
moment, we are friends.
And also, we have
shooting with them when
they need something special.
I have to say that I'm
doing, I think, 55%
of my shooting as art.
I don't do it all for the money,
because I want it to be an art.
And I want to take
this process--
because it's all moving me.
It's letting me to grow up.
It lets me to know something
new, and interesting.
And also, I can
speak with the person
and communicate with the person
more time before shooting.
I can speak one time,
but if we have time,
we can just going, speaking,
shooting little bit of 35
millimeter film camera, and
only after two or three weeks,
start to make serious shootings.
So, in this way.
OK?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
in the beginning,
you comment that
you would prefer
five tops-- like, five top
photographers, artists,
painters, movie directors,
cameraman-- like that.
What are your top fives?
Who is on your list?
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: I will
try to tell about it.
I love-- I really appreciate
the work of painters, first.
Yeah?
It's one of Russian painters--
Mikhail Vrubel.
Maybe somebody know him.
Also I loved the [INAUDIBLE],,
the brighter star, for me,
is John Collier.
It's fantastic.
Sometimes, I put his
works on my desktop.
I want to see it more
and more and more.
Also, I like the works
of Franz Winterhalter.
He is making a realistic,
great artistic portraits.
They look like photos.
Also, I like Rembrandt.
Also, I like some classics,
like Leonardo da Vinci,
Michelangelo.
But I want to mention,
also, El Greco.
He's making a little
bit sick paintings,
but they're also
very attractive.
About the cinema
directors, I would want
to mention Martin McDonagh.
I love him very much.
Christopher Nolan.
Alejandro Gonzales Inarritu.
Gus van Sant.
And Alfonso Cuarron,
also-- one of my favorites.
About cameramen, maybe I will
not just now remember all five.
But I am really impressed
by works of Chivo--
Emmanuel Lubezki.
And we're speaking a
little bit on Instagram.
It's also about
great possibilities
of communication--
that I can, sometimes,
communicate with I think
the most amazing cameraman
in the world.
He has sometimes
left in the comments.
And I am just filled--
[LAUGHS] What's going on?
[LAUGHTER]
And also, I love Wally Pfister.
And many other guys.
Rodrigo Prieto.
I love, you know-- this
South American school,
with a very live camera.
And also, when I was
working as a cameraman
on the other projects, I
also like to do live camera.
Because it's giving out a
great presence as viewers.
So-- that's the answer.
SPEAKER: And one more
question, because we're
running out of time.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So, if you
had to choose one lens
and one camera that's
the most fun for you,
what would you choose?
And the reason I'm
asking is because it's
become, like you said, easier
to take pictures today.
And sometimes I leave
my camera at home.
And the camera that's given
me the most joy, by far,
in many years, is
the Fuji Instant.
Because you only have--
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: Nice.
Nice, nice.
AUDIENCE: Because you only
have one try, and it's--
[GROANS]
SERGEI SARAKHANOV: You know, I
wanted to say about Hasselblad.
But you know, I will
say about the phone--
it's a good end of our lecture,
because the phone gives us
great possibilities.
And I can shoot nice portraits,
nice landscapes, nice streets.
And I don't need
to take anything.
Sometimes I'm going to trip,
I'm taking only a film camera
for some serious
shootings for my projects,
and only an iPhone--
or some kind of
Google phone, also.
Pixel, Pixel 2.
So-- guys, thank you a lot.
It's a very big honor
for me to be here, today.
I want to say, great things
to my friends who helped me
to [INAUDIBLE] this text.
So I have you--
I want to wish you great
and good luck, and more,
more photos.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]